[Musique]
les enfants
que ça sent bon patron collaro qu'est-ce
qui sent bon nounours vous ne sentez pas
le parfum de la cuisine que prépare le
grand chef cuisinier l'ours mais non tu
n'as pas encore commencé
du rêve ce jeu refait mais je couvre je
vole à mais fort le
tient bien ton échelle et descend
sagement peu de pop home
depot prenait lé voilà grands chefs nous
nous en cuisiniers oui dépêchons nous
prépare la cuisine
chez kana on va bien s'amuser
voyons tout est en ordre
de la moutarde
et des fines herbes
chef
bonsoir mes petits or je sens que nous
allons faire de la grande cuisine
que voulez-vous que je vous prépare
a toujours de bonnes idées de jeu des
côtelettes marie louise
deux corps paul fischer merci non pas
pour moi non plus merci quelque chose de
plus cuisiner
l'afutt il et mougins des crêpes suzette
ou des baigneurs anna des beignets
d'accord pour lé bénin mais du sérieux
je vous prie
car la cuisine c'est une chose sérieuse
[Musique]
donnez-moi saladier avec 250 g de farine
de gollion
chef
[Musique]
et puis une passe et de celle de l'huile
toulouse et de l'eau à trous le et
délayez la basse avec une cuillère en
droit
et tous morts vous m'en voyez plein de
farine et le sucre sous ben rien le
sucre
à présent je vais cuir la poêle huile
l'huile chaude pourrez vous brûlez
éloignez-vous c'est plus prudent
rester devant la porte je vous appelle
d'un côté tu es
[Musique]
idiot et si c'était réussi ses beignets
tendu vous faudra taper les pompiers
gros chef ça va tu vois là les baigneurs
ils sont magnifiques
dit que coûte le premier cachet
attention je fais
[Musique]
quand on est gourmand et comprend le
plus grand bien bon appétit
[Musique]
-
tu sais on aime bien faire de lacunes
avec tous
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo nounours tu as fait de la grande
cuisine que le fut mais
vous ne s'agit pas ce n'est rien la
merci patron je lui a valu en route
bonne idée enfants faute pour
[Musique]
e
où